الازمات لا تاتي فرادا على العراق وشعبه
سياسيا اقتصاديا واجتماعيا اخر الازمات
الجفاف نهر ديالى الواقع شرق بغداد اصبحت
مياهه بحله في مشهد يسلط الضوء على ازمه
الجفاف غير المسبوقه التي تعانيها مناطق
عده في العراق يعيش العراق موسم جفاف
يعتبر الاسوا منذ اكثر من تسعه عقود مع
تراجع هطول الامطار وانحسار مياه الانهار
بحسب الامم المتحده يعدل العراق من بين
خمس دول تعتبر اكثر تاثرا بتغير المناخي
ايضا مع مواجهه ارتفاع كبير في درجات
الحراره الجفاف يضرب محافظه دياله التي
اعتادت سابقا على وفره كبيره خلال المواسم
الزراعيه وهو ما تغير خلال هذا العام
وسائل الاعلام عراقيه نقلت عن مسؤولين في
المحافظه قولهم ان المحافظه بحاجه لدعم
مالي من الحكومه للقضاء على ازمه الجف
وايش حلميه دعينا الحكومه الى اسعافها
لمواجهه الازمه الخنقه التي تكررت تحذيرات
المسؤولين منها على مدار الاشهر الماضيه
[موسيقى]
المره الرابعه يعني الموسم الرابع 4 سنوات
جدا
على المتاح في سجون وخزاناتنا مما اجبرنا
على تحديد
المساحات المزروعه من الموجب الشتويه
نهر ديالا هو اهم روافد نهر دجله لكنه ليس
الوحيد في هذه الازمه منذ نحو 20 عاما
يعاني العراق شحال واضحا في المياه لدرجه
ان بعض مناطق نهر دجله يمكن عبورها مشيا
على الاقدام في المناطق التي ضربها الجفاف
في العراق تقلصت المساحات الزراعيه باهم
المحاصيل الاستراتيجيه في مقدمتها القمح
والارز بالاضافه الى المحاصيل العقليه
والخضراوات ولتعويد المساحات الزراعيه
المفقوده يتجه المزارعون لاستخدام المياه
الجوفيه للزراعه في محاوله الاسباب لكن ما
زاد من ازمه الجفاف تغيير مسارات الانهار
القادمه من ايران اضافه لانشاء سدود
وانفاق مائيه ما دفع احد ملاك قطعان
المواشي الاتهام ايران بزياده الازمه
السوءه
النيران والحلال